So let's begin with the server-client model, and then the high-level concepts that Unreal
introduces when it comes to networked games. We're all familiar with the networking concepts
of server and client, so with these in mind, let's take a look at how Unreal structures
its networked games.
In networking terms, a game made in Unreal can take either or both of these shapes,
that being a single player or local multiplayer shape, and the other being a fully networked
multiplayer game. In a single player or local multiplayer game, the game is run locally
as a standalone executable. Players will supply the input to a single computer and
control everything directly, and this means that everything in the game including actors,
the world and even the user interface for each of those players will exist on that
local machine. Whereas in a networked game, the server will hold the one true and authoritative
state of the game. In this case, a player will connect to the server, which is more
than likely a different machine, as a client. They will then each remotely control a
pawn that the server provides and that they will own. This pawn and the controller that
possesses the pawn will act as a bridge that allows the player to send remote procedure
calls to the server in order for them to perform any given gameplay action. However,
it is key to note that the server will not stream any sort of visuals to the client.
Instead, the server will simply replicate information about the game to each of those
connected clients. So for example, the server will replicate actors so that the client
will know what actors they need to be able to see as well as replicating any data that will
tell the clients how those actors should behave. Each client in turn will take this data and
simulate a very close approximation of what is happening on the server. So now we can see
that in network games, we suddenly have to deal with a lot more nuance in terms of where
data is stored and what has got authority over it. We essentially have two running processes
and a lot of our time is spent dealing with and managing what process has access to what
information. For instance, the game mode only exists server side whilst all VFX is
likely to exist client side. When it comes to servers, Unreal provides two types of
server that we can run. The first is a dedicated server and this runs as a separate
process and it's likely on a remote machine. It does not render any visuals and no clients
are playing locally. It also focuses on maintaining the authoritative state of the game and
it will receive information from clients to verify. The alternative is a listen server
and this is going to run on the same machine as the client that is hosting it. The hosting
player's client will still run the visuals and these are typically acceptable for small-scale
casual multiplayer or cooperative games. So now that we know how Unreal structures
our networked and single-player games as well as what types of server that we can
deploy, we should take a look at what the connection process to Unreal is like. After
all, a server without any clients isn't actually a networked game. Here we can see a high-level
flow of how we get our client into that game. The first step is to have our client
request a connection to the server. At this point, our server can decide whether
or not to accept that connection at all. Once the connection is accepted, the server
will send information to that client for them to proceed. At this point, the server
will tell the client what map to load and then proceed to wait for that client
to load into that map. Once the server receives this callback, the pre-login function
is called in the game mode and this is a critical step as it allows the game mode
to either accept or reject the connection itself. So carrying on from there, if
accepted, the server will then call the login function in the game mode
and this will create the player's controller on the server which will
then be replicated down to that connecting client. It's also really
important to note that the begin play will happen here for that newly
created player controller. Lastly, the server will call the post login
function in the game mode and so at this point it's safe to call any RPC
functions on that player controller. It's fully initialised and we now
have access to any networked functionality.